welcome to the second episode of
trickest line against the king's Gambit
where we are going to continue with the
mainline move e captures
D5 whereupon rather than playing the old
line stuff E4 I do recommend you go with
the modern approach starting with e
captures F4 where black has created the
first threat namely Queen to H4 check so
that let's say if white ignore this and
play a random move d4 then the opening
disaster is looming at the air as the
Tactical point is after G3 Pawn takes G3
and Knight to F3 black can sack his
Queen by playing G2 check and after
Knight takes H4 and the move Pawn takes
rook in the corner promoting a new Queen
if you look at the end result black
clearly emerg with a pce advantage so no
white has to stop this nasty Queen check
by black so accordingly Knight to F3 is
the only fitting reply here and after
this we play Knight to
F6 number one attacking this Pawn number
two reaching the most critical position
of this amazing
line well as I have highlighted over
here white has five m choices and
amongst them three of them try to hang
on to this spawn but let's start where
why plays some routine moves such as
D4 well I'm afraid this is not good as
black can instantly get Advantage with
Knight captures D5 and even though white
has two choices neither of them give any
satisfied results for example more
oftenly played move here is C4 which I'm
afraid a big time mistake as after
Bishop to B4 check if Bishop to D2 then
we can play Knight to E3 attacking the
queen and after some simple obvious
moves Queen to E2 Bishop takes D2 Knight
takes D2 and when black castle at this
point if you carefully look at this
position not only white cannot Castle
but black has a threat of Knight to C2
as well as rook to8 and don't forget he
is a clear Pawn
up so this is a completely hopeless
position for white so that's why after
this check white has to play King to F2
but in the opening your King has to move
like this then there is something really
bad going to happen and obviously black
can play Knight to E3 which pushed the
king more on the center side and I just
like to show you one model game from the
database where black simply Play Bishop
to
G4 white thought okay I can play Bishop
to e to arrange the artificial Castle
but it's too little too late as Knight
to C6 pressurize the D pawn and black
has a very simple plan namely Queen
check and castle on the queen side where
white king is feeling the big time
hit in fact the game finished very
quickly
white plays D5 black give this check and
after King to F2 indeed Castle on the
queen side which pinned down the D pawn
and after Knight to D2 trying to get the
pieace black play a crafty move Rook to
E8 whereupon some nasty tactics on there
so white thought that okay let me get
the king out as quickly as possible with
Rook to E one but what has been missed
out
is after just two moves white resigned
the game can you see
it go ahead and pause the video I'm
showing you right now Queen to E3 check
King to F1 and now this wonderful
deciding blow Bishop to C5 where mate is
unavoidable for the
white
okay the second most popular choice here
is Bishop to C4 and against this my
recommendation is you start with Bishop
to
E6 which has a very cute trap and many
people fall for this that white cannot
Castle here the simple reason is black
has this amazing resource Knight to E3
which by force wins The Exchange after
Bishop Bishop takes E3 Bishop takes C4
both of the white pieces are hanging so
when white save the bishop we take the
rook and at the end what else an
exchange of at just 10th move of the
game so this is a nice trap which you
should always look out in your Blitz and
the quick games however the accurate
response is Bishop takes C4 where
White's idea is after Queen takes D5 he
wants to take the4 Pawn
but immediately taking on F4 is not
possible as few people fall for this
because of this wonderful check and
nabbing the bishop so watch out for this
tactic when Queen is on the D5
Square well before capturing on F4 white
has to
Castle and even though database suggests
that black should play Bishop to D6 I
don't like the position after Knight to
C3
so rather than going for all this I
recommend this simple approach Knight to
C6 and when white get his Pawn back you
can continue with Castle on the quein
side putting the pressure on the D Pawn
so C3 is almost forced here but after
that this nice little move F6 gives
black a hell lot of fun position as you
can see from the arrows G5 H5 coming up
very thick and fast and although game is
double-edge if you run this position in
any chess engine it clearly favors the
black the second move I want to consider
is Knight to
C3 whereupon we can simply take on D5
and funny enough white has three
different choices but I'm afraid neither
of them are walking here for example if
he plays the moood D 4 then we can play
Bishop to B4 pinning down the Knight and
after Bishop to D2 what else this simple
sequence Bishop takes C3 Pawn takes C3
and now Castle on the king side where
black has some obvious moves Knight to
E3 as well as Rook to E8 and altogether
with a pawn Advantage this is already
looking Grim for the white Camp so no D4
is a bad choice in this
positions what about other choice if
your opponent continue with Knight takes
D5 then you can simply recapture with
the queen and the point is after
D4 you don't need to play the favorite
database Choice Bishop to D6 rather
Bishop to E7 is most accurate
choice because white is not threatening
here Bishop takes F4 due to this check
which we have already seen so far so
that is right out of the equation and
overall black has a very simple plan he
wants to play G5 and hang on to this
extra Pawn so for example a simple line
can goes like this C4 Queen to D6 Bishop
to D3 planning to Castle where we can
first spin down this Knight and after
Castle indeed play G5 where black has to
follow very simple Theory take out the
Knight Castle on the Quin side and with
extra Pawn you get some good attack on
the white
king so last but not least what happens
if your opponent continue with moves
such as Bishop to C4 which is highest Le
played here but this is again not
working in this position because of
Knight captur C3 and it doesn't matter
however white
recapture let's say B capture C3 is
databas STP Choice against both of this
move black will hold on to his extra
material with Bishop to
D6 and castle castle what else a clear
material advantage for the
black okay so let's look at some of the
serious options by the white where white
really want to hold on to this extra
material and amongst them the most
popular choice from the database is to
play
C4 looks very impressive
right well guess what against all of
these three options my recommendation is
very simple and you are going to
remember the theory in a very effective
manner first you can play C6 attack ATT
in the D5 and obvious enough white has
to take
it well there are some games starting
with D4 but I think after this white get
an iqp which is a clearcut Target in the
upcoming end game and the line goes like
this bishop to B4 check if Bishop to D2
then we can exchange the bishop so
Knight to C3 and now you can take on D5
all in white to capture his Pawn back
but then we can Castle on the king's
side and the big point is when white
moves the bishop we can take on
C4 gaining one important Tempo and not
only that after Bishop takes C4 if you
carefully look at the position white get
an horrible weakness on the
dile and on top of everything we have a
forcing sequence which goes as follow
Knight to D5 double attack white has to
play Bishop to D2 now you give this
check so white Bishop has to go back now
you take on C3 and after Pawn takes C3
and the move Queen to E7 just carefully
look at this position guys not only
white has some horrible Pawn structure
but his King stuck in the center and
sooner or later black can exploit these
factors in his favor with some careful
play for example one of my recent game
my opponent plays C4 here and after my
Bishop to D7 he thought hang on he
blunder a piece so I will take it but
after my next move white get the rude
shock did you spot
it Bishop to A4 a deflection move and
poor White Queen cannot
move well he tried Bishop to B4 trying
to give the piece back but I was more
than happy as after Queen captures B4
check Queen to D2 and queen to
E7 once again the black threat remain as
it is as you cannot Castle but on top of
everything white has this time really
horrible structure and if you look at
the engine Evolution here clearly it is
black who can have a lot of fun in this
line well as per the database the most
popular choice is Pawn takes
C6 and now black can take back the pawn
with the Knight where upon D4 has been
exclusively played
here looks very natural you are taking
the center and attacking on F4 but in
fact here fun begins for the black with
this nice tactical move Bishop to
G4 where he has targeted the D
Pawn okay white has two choices and
amongst them once again D5 is a by far
most popular choice but I'm afraid this
is a huge mistake as after Bishop have
three white has two choices and both of
them leads to
disaster first move Queen captures F3 a
natural move but leading to a
high-profile trap here guys as black has
this forcing sequence Knight to D4
double attack White Queen has to go on
the
dile now you play Bishop to
C5 allowing White white to take back the
pawn but after our Castle threatening
Rook to E8 so white plays the move
Knight to
C3 and when black give this check his
idea is to play Bishop to E2 so that his
peace is well protected and he ready to
Castle except one problem that here
black has a move which force the
resignation the question is can you find
it you are a genius if you see the move
Bea what a move and the idea is very
simple this is the only piece which is
defending on E2 so by playing the move
before before we are dislodging it and
getting a piece advantage
okay white has few options for example
if he plays movees such as A3 then we
can simply take on C4 forcing the queen
to go
away so that we can deliver this juicy
Fork so that is right out of the
equation what about castle well that
straight will run into of a tactic that
is B4 attacking two
pieces and last but not Le least many of
you says that hang on can't why just
take this pawn and neutralize all black
threats well of course he can accept one
problem that now D5 Pawn become weak and
black can simply chop it off which comes
with a double thread so that after
Bishop to D2 We can take on C3 and then
take on E2 with a clear piece advantage
well apart from D5 white can also Play
Bishop to E2 in this
position and his idea is when black take
this Knight he wants to recapture with
the bishop so that if you take on D4
then white Bishop can take on
B7 and yes at first s side this looks
cool except one problem that black has
this lethal check whereupon white is
finding some really difficult time for
example you cannot play Queen to E2 due
to D4 Pawn
hangs and queen to E7 Bishop E7 you
cannot take on B7 as Knight to C2 check
so most of the games continue with
Bishop to D1 but after this black has a
very simple task Bishop to D6 protect
the pawn castle with a healthy Pawn
advantage
so NOP Queen to E2 is a big mistake here
what about King to
F2 well this time around we can Castle
on the quein side setting yet another
trap and this has recently happened in
my blit game my opponent thought wow I
can take on C6 destroying black queen
side and now play Rook to e where I'm
going to do artificial castle and
everything is so good but but what he
missed is black has this nice shot Rook
captures D4 and suddenly white is a
complete Pawn down for absolutely no
compensation as Queen captures D4 run
into this very nice tactic Knight to G4
check King to F1 Knight to H2 check King
to F2 and after Queen check when white
king goes to E2
black has this winning moon in the
picture F3 a double attack so King has
been detached from the rook and after
that yep what else you can take it and
on top of white naked King black has a
outright passer and altogether this is
completely dominating position for
black one of my favorite trap do if your
opponent continue with Bishop to E2 as
now you get this cute sequence Castle on
the Quin side attacking on D4 in the
majority of the games white played the
move D5 and after this just look at this
forcing sequence guys
F3 white has to take it otherwise he's
going to lose a
piece and now because the F pawn move
forward the king become extremely weak
and exactly on this point black can
deliver this nasty night
sacrifice
boom what a move and the thing is after
Pawn takes D5 and this queen
check you cannot go to D5 so King to
have fun his
firstc and after this I think white is
completely losing with Bishop to
C5 where mating attack is
unavoidable and there is a game in the
database where white plays King to
G2 only to find the Finishing Touch Rook
to D6 and what else a beautiful
miniature by the
[Music]
Black